Entonces, ¿dónde están los robots?
Nos han dicho por 40 años que ya vienen.
Muy pronto estarán haciendo todo por nosotros:
cocinarán, limpiarán, comprarán, construirán. Pero aún no están aquí.
Mientras tanto tenemos inmigrantes ilegales haciendo todo el trabajo,
pero no tenemos robots.
¿Qué podemos hacer al respecto? ¿Qué podemos decir?
Quiero compartir un poco de otra perspectiva,
de cómo quizás podamos ver estas cosas de forma ligeramente distinta.
Y esta es una foto de rayos X
de un escarabajo y un reloj suizo, del año 1988. Viendo eso,
lo que fue cierto entonces es cierto hoy.
Podemos hacer las piezas y hacerlas correctamente,
podemos hacer los circuitos para una capacidad de cómputo adecuada,
pero en la práctica no podemos unirlos para construir algo
que realmente funcione y sea tan adaptable como estos sistemas.
Así que intentemos verlo desde una perspectiva diferente.
Llamemos al mejor diseñador, la madre de todos los diseñadores:
veamos que puede hacer por nosotros la evolución.
Entonces mezclamos, creamos una sopa primordial
con montones de piezas de robots, con barras, motores, neuronas.
Los juntamos todos, pusimos todo eso bajo cierta clase de selección natural,
bajo mutación, y recompensamos la capacidad de avance.
Una tarea muy simple, y es interesante ver la clase de cosas que surgen de ahí.
Así que si observan, pueden ver un montón de máquinas diferentes
saliendo de esto. Todas se mueven,
todas ellas se arrastran a su manera y, pueden ver a la derecha
que efectivamente hemos fabricado un par de estas cosas,
y funcionan en el mundo real. No son robots muy fantásticos pero
evolucionaron para hacer exactamente aquello por lo que los recompensamos;
para moverse hacia adelante. Así que eso fue hecho en simulación
pero también podemos hacerlo en una máquina de verdad.
Aquí está un robot físico que de hecho
tiene una población de cerebros,
compitiendo o evolucionando, en la máquina.
Es como un espectáculo de rodeo: todos se pueden subir a la máquina
y son recompensados por qué tan rápido o qué tan lejos
pueden hacer que la máquina avance.
Y pueden ver que esos robots no están listos
aún para dominar al mundo, pero
aprenden gradualmente a avanzar
y hacen esto de forma autónoma.
Así que en esos dos ejemplos, básicamente tenemos
máquinas que aprendieron cómo caminar en una simulación
y también máquinas que aprendieron cómo caminar en la realidad.
Pero quiero mostrarles un enfoque distinto
y es este robot de aquí, el cual tiene cuatro patas,
tiene ocho motores, cuatro en las rodillas y cuatro en las caderas.
Tiene también 2 sensores de inclinación que le dicen a la máquina
por cuál lado se está inclinando.
Pero esta máquina no sabe cómo es ella misma.
Mirándola sabes que tiene cuatro patas
pero la máquina no sabe si es una serpiente, un árbol,
no tiene ni idea de cómo es
pero va a tratar de descubrirlo.
Al principio, hace algunos movimientos al azar
y entonces intenta descubrir cómo puede ser
y se ven un montón de cosas pasar por "sus mentes",
un montón de modelos de sí misma que tratan de explicar la relación
entre su actuación y su percepción y entonces intenta ejecutar
una segunda acción que genere la mayor discrepancia
entre las predicciones de esos modelos alternativos,
como un científico en un laboratorio. Entonces hace eso
e intenta explicarlo y depura sus modelos de sí misma.
Este es el último ciclo y pueden ver que prácticamente
ha descubierto cómo es y una vez que tiene un modelo de sí misma,
puede usarlo para derivar un patrón de locomoción.
Así que lo que ven aquí son un par de máquinas,
un patrón de locomoción.
Esperábamos que fuera a tener un tipo de andar maligno, arácnido,
pero en cambio creó esta forma de avanzar bastante patética.
Pero cuando miran eso tienen que recordar
que esta máquina no hizo ningún ensayo físico sobre cómo avanzar,
ni tenía un modelo de sí misma.
Más o menos descubrió cómo era, y cómo podía avanzar,
y entonces lo intentó en realidad.
(Aplausos)
Entonces, probemos una idea diferente.
Eso fue lo que ocurrió cuando teníamos un par de...
fue lo que ocurrió cuando tienes un par... OK, OK, OK,
(Risas)
no se caen bien. Entonces
hay un robot diferente.
Eso fue lo que ocurrió cuando los robots fueron
recompensados por hacer algo.
¿Qué ocurre si no los recompensas en lo absoluto, si sólo los pones ahí?
Tenemos estos cubos, como el diagrama muestra aquí.
El cubo puede girar, o ponerse de lado,
y dejamos mil de esos cubos en una sopa,
esto es en simulación, y no los recompensamos por nada,
sólo los dejamos dar vueltas. Le insertamos energía a esto
y vemos que ocurre en un par de mutaciones.
Al principio no pasa nada, sólo están dando de vueltas por ahí.
Pero muy poco después puedes ver esas cosas azules
a la derecha que empiezan a prevalecer.
Empiezan a autorreplicarse. Así que en ausencia de toda recompensa
la recompensa intrínseca es autorreplicación.
Y de hecho hemos construido un par de éstos
y esto es parte de un robot más grande hecho con estos cubos,
es una vista acelerada donde puedes ver al robot
ejecutando parte de su proceso de replicación.
Así que si estás dándole más material, cubos en este caso,
y más energía y puede hacer otro robot.
Por supuesto, es una máquina muy rudimentaria
pero estamos trabajando en una versión a microescala,
esperando que algún día los cubos sean como un polvo que puedas echar.
¿Qué podemos aprender? Estos robots, por supuesto,
no son muy útiles por sí mismos pero podrían enseñarnos algo
sobre cómo podemos construir mejores robots
y quizás cómo los humanos y animales crean modelos de sí mismos y aprenden.
Y una de las cosas que creo es importante
es que tenemos que abandonar esta idea
de diseñar máquinas manualmente
sino más bien dejarlas evolucionar y aprender, como niños,
y quizás esa es la forma en que lo consigamos. Gracias.
(Aplausos)